what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch x gon
give it to you fast ex the day John how
excited are you I'm so excited to be
back with my family guys you know what
to do go ahead leave a like that would
mean the world we have bought this v-o-d
I'm excited to see Vin D and Jason Momoa
let's swing into it but before that a
word from our sponsor there's an
alluring Aroma in the air thanks to our
sponsor scentbird scentbird is the
ultimate fragrance Subscription Service
offering over 600 designer Brands to
choose from they have perfumes cologne
and even unisex options you can find
favorites like Prada Gucci Versace and
even some very much beloved Indie labels
for just 17 a month you get to try a new
designer fragrance of your choice it's
flexible too allowing you to skip any
month without penalties and if you're
craving even more variety you can
upgrade to receive two or three products
a month each fragrance comes with a 30
day supply giving you an opportunity to
try right out before committing to a
full bottle I really believe when it
comes to fragrance it's all about
variety and discovering new brands plus
as a married man adding an attractive
new scent can truly spice things up I
selected four fragrances and my wife she
loved them all sweet taboo by Chris
Collins warm and inviting this scent
breaks taboos in search of pleasure
Gourmand notes like coffee cardamom and
vanilla create a seductive atmosphere
that few can resist bearberry for men a
powerful combination of green apple and
Peach top notes complemented by Vanilla
Jasmine mint lime and Sandalwood offer a
sophisticated Counterpoint to the Regal
sweetness Michael's remains sexual steel
intensely charismatic this fragrance
Blends fresh ginger and smooth Bergamot
with the magnetic lavender and crushed
black pepper it dries down to a
seductive mix of metal Accord masculine
leather and musk Mind Games inspired by
the Brilliance of Chess this fragrance
captivates with the Exquisite florals
and transforms into unmatched strength
energizing coffee notes mingle with
spicy seduction of incense mirror and
dark wood so ladies and gents if you
want to have fun choosing and get your
first box going click the link below and
use my code rejects for 55 off your
first month at scentbird that's only
about eight dollars for your first month
seriously great deal so thank you again
semford for your support oh yeah totally
forgot to mention fully threat to watch
a long race sync up with your own copy
of fast sex that is available for our
super sexual rejects over at our patreon
page feel free to pledge and join us
over there that would mean a lot anyway
let's watch this for real
this is a company specifically formed
for a fast move ten years ago yes we're
returning back to Fast Five your mother
have understood this she looked at you
and saw a monster I saw potential are we
in the vault it is Dominic Torito burn
what is mine I'll kill Dominic Toronto
no my son we're suffering you soon never
accept death as a payment stupid
the word begins and in there
today we'll put our family on a path to
willpower oh do I see Alan Richardson's
body oh is it I heard he's in is he
getting some Reacher
[Music]
yes
I too remember the best fast and furious
love this rashamon perspective
make him suffer make him suffer make
himself
[Music]
no I do miss Paul Walker
I would love with the events of this
Chase just set up an alternate timeline
[Applause]
last one
I don't remember the events well enough
to remember if that car was the one that
got hit if there was even a Gatling I
don't even remember go back into a side
by side
yeah boy
didn't do enough Donuts you had it I
didn't have it you almost had me
no one starts at the Finish Line you
gotta have faith oh my God Little Brian
it's like his old man
remember today's lesson find the line
feel the car and let it fly and win the
Oscar oh yes
Rita Moreno better drive a car by the
end of this movie where's Brian
so much pride a kind of Pride that my
son would have enjoyed if he were here I
know that this road has been very hard
what's Dominic's race
it's a lot of things
it is a legacy that will go on for
Generations Legacy no one could take it
away not now not ever yeah not even
Jason Momoa
especially not Jason Momoa Roman asked
if he could lead this mission
how can I tell him no simple he's the
dumbest one yeah you should never tell
him yes let's spend the lyrics for Life
callbacks oh is that a call back to the
it was like some short film Vin Diesel
directed yeah is that the one I'm
thinking of is that right comment below
comment you're at Vin Diesel directorial
efforts expert I just because certainly
sounds familiar
oh
oh you all know his name
Hold Us in your heart and you will never
lose your way
Spirit of family
see you again you know we're in the car
today they said Daddy you're never
afraid I'm afraid of losing a son or a
wife like family no
oh it's [__] hot Lord
you know what you miss
why
eternity
in
this moment
the heart of a warrior
new DeLorean when did this happen
oh my God it's Hobbes
got a makeover Oh no you're marked wait
who is this
Cipher oh landed the plane got out of
jail
imagine killing you a thousand times
I couldn't reach you then
no I can't You're Gonna Want to hear my
last words
don't you think I'd have a goddamn good
reason to be here
maybe the only reason that's ever
mattered to you you really shouldn't
move dumb yeah I'm out of targets on
your back this house has been exploded
once everyone knows where you live
I'm at the Devil tonight honestly I
always thought it was me so that was
kind of disappointing
[Laughter]
you're still the devil don't worry I'm
here because
Emily this is you
I am a man with no name Dante
Dante Reyes
but I need your help
you thought you could use my own move
against me I wasn't talking to you I was
talking to Zeke
Kevin's dad oh it's cold it's clever
[Music]
oh damn he's good all these henches have
family
oh my god wow it's been right to murder
[Laughter]
the rest of you have a choice me or
that was well done I will remember this
I think everyone will
devil oh and just like that Vin Diesel
was mad at him for stealing the
spotlight
that's why you don't put computers in a
gun did you think I would trust you
wow
now Cipher is going to kill all their
families just to make a point
ouchy
ah damn it
damn whoa let's get a little of that
you're right here with me
yes
[Music]
oh
damn this is awesome at this
oh that was cool
oh wow
damn cypher's best scene yeah I try to
get in touch with Roman Ramsay Han no
answer any idea where they might be in
Rome working for you we don't have a
mission in Rome
Roman [__]
we're going to Rome
Roman lead you and I will finish that
driving lesson it's a promise no matter
what happens I always keep my promises
who's gonna stay with him you're gonna
call Brian to babysit well the sooner we
break into the truck and steal the chip
the sooner you get to live La Dolce Vita
Roman the Cowboys almost in position
where the hell are you at Sweet Life of
tejan Roman he's finally leading a
mission and it's pointless yep two tiny
tennis wait wait hold up tiny chairs
what are you talking about woman
[Laughter]
just so you know tiny tej's brain still
bigger than yours they gave him like the
bobble head like the Ludicrous video
oh they're just driving looking forward
[Laughter]
[Music]
come on
multi-skilled these are field hackers
it's really dangerous to be on that oh
there's no one driving it
[Music]
this vehicle is just greater alignment
yeah this guy's gonna run over
good luck
and a one and a two
[Music]
it's a great reaction a little too much
in huh ready
oh geez that's a big ass bomb
[Music]
Utah messed up Roman hey dorks what are
we blowing up what
Vatican okay I'll do it
I love him put him in every movie
I can disarm it with an agency kill
switch I just need physical hands on the
device we have to stop that truck sorry
Captain America again let's do that did
you audition for Captain is that like an
Easter egg Dominic
oh come on
dammit he's fast goddamn radius
let's do this
[Music]
nicely done how did that work exactly
[Applause]
wow
holy moly shark's about to go over the
hill we have to crash into it yes we do
oh they're gonna stop it yeah stop the
momentum
no we got this
what are you gonna do lady she's gonna
pick up the bomb all by herself throw it
into the ocean
protect our oceans little B
itch oh my god wow this is like an
Uncharted level yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a wild ass sequence yeah at a
good like call back to the safe a sphere
instead of a cube it's great
I think I found our God
[Music]
[Laughter]
is he gonna like drag the bomb I don't
know
created a cover to cover for them oh wow
he saved their lives damn look at that
that cloth awning really protected those
people from fire and explosion
[Music]
oh protect that face
literally his name
or his call
signal
that laugh of his oh
yeah nice they are delivering ah
good thing nothing could fall over there
never mind
ah
that is just Gathering more and more
fire
jeez has like no one died yet
that's what's really good at dodging
this bomb oh wow
that fire went out fast
I love that a little bit of water yeah
no no more air intake
good little splash
[Applause]
yes
Bravo Ramsay how deep is that River 60
feet I mean the water could smother the
explosion reduce its power by 10 times
maybe
oh no
I missed it by that much of how no one
suspicious of him nope we can stop the
chase now got 30 seconds to save Rome
the arm to the bomb and you're almost at
the river
really oh boy where yeah
oh there's the river
yes yes
vaticans within the blast radius get out
of there you've done everything you
could not everything
oh Jesus Take the Wheel
s
oh my god wow
[Applause]
[Music]
push it down dog yes
through your suffering
my destiny
and find me your pain has just begun to
the pain the Vatican has sustained some
structural damage no lines were claimed
[__] what did they just say first
mobilizing an international future
stealing a 20 kiloton bomb oh come on
with little nobody out of commission and
your daddy in the wind talking to the
new boss Showtime uh-oh so she's the
daughter I guess so nobody's got a
family too they ran missions for us in
Abu Dhabi Tokyo London New York that's
their MO to corrupt law enforcement they
literally brought him here to do like a
a Reacher performance yep you know the
thing you're doing on your show do that
here
what's your point point is they're
criminals Rome was a matter of time
they've stolen hundreds of millions of
dollars in at least one nuclear sub God
damn right great exact footage from the
movies
finished effects I'm asking for Full
Green Light Authority killer captured
the Toretto Clan by any means Ames what
are you doing he's going through the
Continental you guys have questions
after that comprehensive recap of the
series the team's gone to ground they're
safe for now they've taken Letty whoever
did this wanted to sever your ties to
the agency and isolate you from your
family
Dominic Toretto Rogue Nation
our fugitives aren't unknown quantities
Toretto has a sister a son until we find
him find his family you're the new
Hobbes Hobbs Reacher
oh boy
yeah this is necessary
for this little boy and let's destroy
the house again you really should move
whoa
[Music]
oh did Little B do that John Cena that's
a good guess actually I forgot his name
Jacob with a k
yes yes good call so Uncle Jacob your
dad sent me yes
[Laughter]
kill our allies
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
wrestling moves
the base God
that one
it's a heavy ass door you okay
the face
the agency needs better gear yeah dude
Louis the terrier did an amazing job
with this I'm enjoying this way more
than F9 oh yeah wait oh yeah 100 it's
actually fun yeah
oh my God let me drive cool Uncle Jacob
it's not that one
it's this one yeah
inconspicuous
was that from like 1990 how about around
on me huh
I'm counting on it
how well look there's no code no one's
safe the agency has turned its back on
everything it stood for working with
criminals
yep Hernan Ray is still pretty dead he
has a son Dante Letty letty's in a black
site prison off of every map and get her
out nobody can but you're a nobody you
are a nobody what you're asking me to do
is impossible
Jesus will be with you yes
my first family nothing's impossible
this movie pushing religion on me
or need your agenda okay
undisclosed location Germany
what the hell keeping her in an Indiana
Jones tomb fancy coat expensive earrings
those gotta hurt
whoa nice I'm out here for the agency
I'm gonna get you out of here but it's
gonna take some time you didn't come all
this way without a plan game recognizes
game oh
first let's get you out of the cell It's
Gonna Hurt
me
open the door smart
really yeah really no smart she's moving
you I'm just looking for someone how can
we help
sure
Kentucky you already did
I saw the subtitles
oh my God ready to roll
never mind who is this Daniella melchior
I'm not sure she usually has shorter
hair
[Applause]
a million dollars for whoever can beat
me no he's dressed
love it full hairy styles
this looks like a genie
rub the car three times and make a wish
I'm Dante I'm Shantae
[Laughter]
you remember my father I remember he
thought he had his foot on a serious
neck but you know what happened he got
his next step
is mine and I own this thing nice
loyalty
she can't buy the streets sure you can
though the streets the streets are
typically going for a price we race if
you win you take me in if you lose don't
lose contractually I can't Let's Race
[Music]
no we're putting our attention to the
side
everybody Stow your weapons
I actually like their back and forth
yeah it's been a long time since I've
been like oh I've seen Vin Diesel bounce
off to someone yeah well there's
contrast now
I'm just here to wreck all of the like
forced gravitas
I know what you're thinking and yes
carpet matches the drapes thank you
you've saved so many lives oh I know I
can't figure it out how do you choose
the ones you save uh-oh what does he put
on the line
oh look at that it's like out of the
first movie
yeah
like actual Jason no it seems like
nobody directed him
just let him take carp launch to be
everyone I love it it works though
oh you're too eager
oh no choice
he wouldn't put a bomb under her car
[Music]
did uh you gotta save her
what are you gonna save him he knows him
but he's gonna save both of them
[Music]
looks like you made your choice
[Applause]
ah trick question everyone dies
well done
[Music]
they saved the semi-famous one yep
like a little John yeah because I'm out
of here you're still beautiful I saved
you for your looks let me wipe this one
piece of dirt off your face
did you know whoa listen to me did you
know that I was legally dead for two
minutes two minutes
yes
[Music]
he's the Joker
Batman of the Joker
and everyone drives at the Batmobile
should we take all their money
oh my yes he totally Richard them too
nope
there are a lot of plots in this movie
that's what I come here for just like
just like cutting to so many different
plots
eyes open hold still don't smile like
that it's unsettling
your new name is Chester Chester and
you're on a kayaking trip with your
handsome
ripped Uncle Roger Chester and Raj we
gotta get ready to fight wait so we need
guns artillery tanks yeah but how we
gonna get that with no money we've been
hacked you guys are the hackers
we need more computing power yeah we're
gonna do that if we broke what do you
mean we broke
oh my God Roman you did something smart
I'm a grown ass
yes
you remind me who I was all alone didn't
you from The Moment I Saw You sisters
[Laughter]
yeah does anyone and only child in this
universe you know Elena she knew
everything about the Reyes family after
they killed her husband she dedicated
her life trying to take them down I
think I still have her files you just
have her files yep so remember her by
if I die I want you to have my case
files
for me you
Freddie Merc
we need transport weapons cars and
quietly cool but I'm just gonna need
cash oh the black Jeff Bezos here's got
you covered
I won't even cover the muffins this guy
serious
yes Han might get his personality back
damn yeah I want an acid trip race
sequence that's all they do is talk and
then everyone has to do their job and
yours he's fantastic you know what I'm
saying hey guys this is a family
environment it's a family
Gentlemen please guys you guys
supporting like dozens of dollars in
damage dozens of dollars in tears
beat your ass you just beat my ass beat
my ass oh my God
just please look how sweaty tires
it looks like Hobbs from Fast Five
they're secretly related
that easy huh why would you ever what
they like to fix things before they
break them sick Place Letty Minority
Report
what did you do I rerouted an aesthetic
gas into their air conditioning
how'd you do that without look looking
she knows rasheed's that well
why would they put it right where your
hand would be
no I do
how much time do we have
about four minutes it'll have to do
yes get a fight in there
I'd stay down if I was you I like
Charlie's throwing a lot in this movie
yeah two baddest ass ladies and Showbiz
getting a showdown
yeah yes
ouch
Sam
[Music]
what
on Earth guys yeah four minutes I think
that was the most unbelievable thing
that's happened so far
yeah
ouch pocket glass
sociopathic tendencies from an early age
he bounced from juvie to prison to
mental words and each time daddy was
there to Spring him out
talk about a glow up properties raise on
before he died
the police station and guess whose name
is on indeed my fun man sit there
it stands to reason we're gonna get up
and go to the bathroom ready
not suspicious we all need to go to the
bathroom yep at the same time it's gonna
be a lot of space on this flight
oh
now let's lose our tail
we going skydiving
oh what they're just flying
is that a little plane you know how to
Glide so we need thrust fuel
alcohol right so three tiny bottles of
alcohol okay that's more like it
that's Rose not gonna work long story a
good initiative
I want to hear you tell that story I'm
glad it wasn't the height enjoy the ride
that'll be
stay based hi base even if you're not
scared of heights it's pretty terrifying
guys hold back no no that's a bad idea I
mean like Roman level bad uh
oh it's these guys no no it's
it's Cliffhanger from last to Statham uh
of course there you go okay I have
something to talk to you about the only
reason a dead guy shows up in my door
[__]
[Music]
oh
go there
and this is how we Bond Wowie
I'm trying to kill me too enemy of my
enemy
wow nicely done tej man
yeah I guess so
now both of you come to the barbecue
hello Dominic until now you have lived
your life a quarter mile at a time you
know what I can't figure out how someone
born so rich chooses the poorest path of
life oh bars I'm gonna break yours the
game's not over yet there's still so
many people to hurt
oh [__] damn it Toretto freeze time to
face the music Dom they're playing right
into his hands cop what surprised
celebrities Gonna Save Dominic's Roto
now
he's trying to tear us apart they've
been paid to Target us and anyone who
ever helped us until now Queenie
mother mom I'll have transport waiting
for you
and where are you going I want to dig
some Graves
with all these guns
what are you doing preparing for what's
to come
oh
he protected Jack Reacher
I feel like I tried doing the cool walk
and then
oh
this also looks like the same freeway
from that one Mission Impossible fight
drink the gasoline yes become a car
it'll happen by the last movie
I'm listening now
ah God is respect I mean he could tell
that Dom's not really the bad guy
you never know he can stay committed is
he picking up a car he is turning a car
over with one hand
he's got he's doing everyone
he's the car Whisperer
[Music]
my family
hey oh [__] with the drip
yes
the Moa has no contract
it hurt me
yep
Swan guy
oh got rid of the vest
oh no she's in Peril I can't save them
all five
four you can't see me
go on
yes Warrior and his shield
gotcha you killed my father on this
bridge and now I know where to find your
son
you're gonna be okay I got her go save
your son my nephew
exactly yeah
I'm not gonna say I'm sorry so let me do
you one better
let's get your son did everyone hear
that conversation
apparently so
you know all that fire and destruction
it's not that loud
project I've been working on
we're going back to space
we gotta go
[Applause]
oh
oh yeah
oh my
missile launcher damn whoa
collateral damage
stuck stuck you gotta crawl out there
kid there's an Airfield seven clicks
West okay we'll meet you there now open
the back up there's really nowhere to
land who said anything about Landing you
got to get to the land yeah to use the
car you will need to be on just jumped
off
I think
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow the guys Dominator is a superhero we
just got to accept it but they're still
on your tail
it's jammed
oh what are you doing yep you knew this
was coming Pete
come on base God you got this
oh my God
ah damn it I would love a scene with him
Dominic welcome to the Big Show dance
the last laugh check out my co-pilot
welcome back three Dom please don't kill
Dante save him for the sequel yeah you
need him
please
looks like my fuel line's been shot I
can't get to him Dom Jacob stay with me
jump into his car you're the star of
this movie Dumb
[Music]
Jesus Take the Wheel
no
[Music]
don't worry in the sequel we'll see how
we got out yeah he he jumped out at the
last rolled off the freeway
take away the streets nah take the Dom
out of the streets but you can't take
the streets out of Dom
[Music]
nah saves everything do it my turn
oh jeez he defeated the two helicopters
now let's finish that driving lesson
feel the car find your line and fly what
does that mean she's gonna jump out or
something
yeah
oh my God is he gonna catch his son yeah
part of flying is the only one to jump
out yeah
yeah that's part of the driving part of
the drug
s
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
no don't kill him
how does he know for sure Optimus Prime
I'm gonna get it he's showing off in
front of your son but honestly did you
really think it was going to be that
easy easy
he threw helicopter
calvary's here we got you Dom
an get out of here it's a trap Robin
you're a terrible leader
everybody get in a car
whoa see that's the problem with having
a big family oh my God can't protect
them all he's looking right at the
camera no no
think everyone's going to end up on your
side problem is amso's mine first
Jack how could you I told you that was
him damn
excellent cash it looked like his frame
yeah and that hair
the next villain is always literally
just around the corner what a mislead we
thought it was our next Hobbs yeah they
used Jack Reacher against us he made one
mistake
you never took my car yes yep drive down
that damn dumb
[Music]
let's go let's go
this is what the universal ride should
feel like
[Music]
oh this is great
no then also gonna come in handy John of
course
whoa whoa yes the nice shot
the Flames are only helping yes he's
gonna time travel
[Music]
way back in the past right before the
first movie
[Music]
now Drive underwater yes turn into a
submarine live life
four knots at a time suffering is over
Dom it's time for you to die
oh excellent he knows he needs to do all
that to take him down yep
crater with an alien ship
the submarine is back
Now where's Hobbs to ride that missile
huh
oh my God is it hurts
away
still think my plan sucks girls get it
done got Wonder Woman we got the Old
Guard all the supers are here
oh damn what a weird spot to end this
really is like a chapter break now let's
watch that post credit scene that
everyone wanted us to know about
oh here it is
oh
take it off come on howdy partner do you
like surprises you've done some
dastardly Dirty Deeds Sheriff he took
the most important thing of my life for
me
yep you don't get off so easy Dom drove
the car
help me you pulled the trigger yeah this
should have been your enemy this whole
movie yeah pretty much
since when does Luke Hobbs go anywhere
with this much on his face when you give
her a reveal yes there he is
The Devil Is Coming For You
law man lying hard to find you some
[__]
standing ass
all right I did miss him I knew it was
kfabe all along over Ephesus on some
[__]
damn all right so is that his spin-off
movie is gonna be him versus Dante
yeah I don't know alrighty let's talk
about it alrighty well I actually
thought the movie was a lot of fun I
like it I instantly could tell within
like the first 30 to 40 minutes I like
it more for definitely more than F9
that's for sure and uh I would say that
ultimately I actually liked it um a lot
more than fate of the Furious as well I
definitely wouldn't put it both like
Fast Five or even the two installments
that came after it uh but this
definitely brought it back more to yeah
this is just genuinely fun I had this
worry in the first like 30 minutes when
I was having fun of okay
it's a fast and furious movie though at
some point this has become like a
tedious Adventure right we're gonna be
like this is going on a little too long
do I feel like it's a little too long
I don't even know if it's really length
that's the problem it's really that's
just some stuff wasn't as there's some
stuff that definitely loses steam it's
momentum the engine stops revving for
certain plot lines that you cut back to
uh around like the hour and a half mark
that there's some plot lines that just
didn't we're just not as engaging
however though overall I still feel like
it didn't ever get to a point where it
completely lost it it never get the
movie itself in total it never reached a
point where I was like I'm ready to
leave I'm ready to check out once it's
gonna wrap up because there'd always be
something that eventually pulls me back
in uh I thought this was a blast of a
film overall so yeah that's just my
general thoughts off of the experience
uh coming off of it but yeah John what
do you think I also had a blast with the
furious and I was also you know second
that I think it's easily better than at
least the previous two installments
because it did have yeah a sense of fun
the entire time the serious stuff the
Vin Diesel trying to win an Oscar stuff
is tempered well enough to sell what
they want you to care about and I feel
like they in this movie especially kind
of realize that part of the magic is
that yeah you're gonna have some stuff
that's crazy and CG elevated and you
know Larger than Life most definitely
but I thought they'd managed to do a
nice balance of stuff that felt at least
like real stunts real cars getting
crashed and banged up and then you have
your you know him throwing helicopters
at things and all that other Jazz and uh
and yeah you know certain plot lines
were more interesting than others but I
was kind of interested at least in what
everyone was doing so it was just kind
of a matter of to what degree yeah and
uh yeah there were I mean we'll we'll
wait and see if uh Jacob Toretto remains
dead but you know like that was kind of
a surprise I mean like I've kind of
gotten used to not being as surprised by
things they're doing in these movies now
um but yeah I don't know I thought
everybody got a chance to shine and uh
it like I said I think the most
important thing like like you touched on
is is the fun factor and yeah I was
never zoning out I was never like come
on or or getting sort of that mind numb
effect when it's just too much like
craziness in your face
um so yeah I thought they managed to
bring this down to the the level I was
hoping for that I like from these movies
certainly yeah it's weirdly it's not the
craziest Fast and Furious movie it's
definitely to me it's not I've heard
some people say that I'm like I don't
know this is the craziest one to buy a
long shot like the rock hanging off a
sub and like guiding a missile or them
going to space I mean they mention those
things but yeah like they do they do
some like crazy ass [__] in here in his
Dominic Toretto more of a superhero now
more than ever I'd say so yeah it's
definitely like that's kind of like the
best role that they give him here is
just to be some guy who's he's most
interesting in action scenes and I
thought he thought he was fine
um like
here's the thing what I heard I heard a
few things
um that Jason Momo is great
and I heard that this movie has an
ending that upset a lot of people
because it's just sort of abruptly ends
it's not a very well handled cliffhanger
that is probably the best thing I could
have heard about this movie because it
prepared me for that to not be like what
the hell in fact I was able to be like
okay I feel like it's about to end yeah
I was able to actually sense it's about
to end right now yeah because everyone
who like was upset about it I kind of
heard them complain about that which
made me go okay I'm ready for I think
this I think this is the portion when
it's gonna end so when it ended I'm like
yeah definitely doesn't feel like a
complete movie it doesn't like it
doesn't feel like they they told us a a
really specific story within this
chapter one of this fast X Trilogy yeah
it does not it feels like a mid-season
finale but I was so prepared for it that
I wasn't bothered because everyone else
had really prepared me for it so I'm
grateful for that the Gal Gadot thing
was not
um ruined for me although I feel like it
was it was like room for me like a year
ago like everyone was talking to me yeah
I'd forgotten all about it time we got
it but she was there I was like oh yeah
yeah that's right she's supposed to be
here raises a lot of questions it does
like where the hell has she been she's
working with Cipher of all people to be
working with yeah that's a little
questionable
um she looks great if she seriously like
I don't believe Jacob's dead no one can
really die this is a supernatural
element even even
um Alan richson whose name character
I've not committed a memory yet but Alan
Richardson or Jack Reacher yeah even
Ames I think Ames there it is even he
says like ungodly things or a godly or
Defying Gravity yes I'm lying about it
that's acknowledging the Ridiculousness
of what they can accomplish and I'm like
all right well I guess they have
meta-humans in this universe Dominic
Toretto and the family are part of that
this is the birth of metahumans yeah uh
but Jason Momoa uh here's the thing I
was expecting everyone else would be
boring and Jason Momoa would be the only
thing entertaining
and what I was surprised by was I liked
a lot more of the people here that I
actually originally anticipated I would
ultimately walk out of this film saying
I enjoyed quite a bit of the characters
but Jason Momoa is definitely the
Highlight uh undoubtedly no no amount of
Praise actually prepared me for it I
really do love him yeah 100 and I think
you need his presence because you know
with both Vin Diesel and and you know
the installments that feature Dwayne
Johnson even though Dwayne certainly
seems like he's more apt to do you know
the comedic side they both are taking
certain things really seriously and I
think it helps this movie to have such
an anarchic presence and such a
gleefully anarchic presence to contrast
all that so that VIN can go and again
try to win that Oscar but you have you
know the Joker Counterpoint to his
Batman he's very much he's he's doing
Joker just without a high-pitched voice
he leans more into the troubled boy
about it like we're Joker has the more
of the mysterious element there's no
mystery to this guy yeah that's that's
the one thing that I would be like he's
not exactly Joker because there's zero
mystery
his origin story is very specific and
there's a one right answer and it's my
daddy yeah yeah and they do have the
thing about him going into like mental
ward units and all that fun stuff uh but
he was he was so natural that it doesn't
feel like he's forcing anything at all
nor is he playing up the psychotic level
to the point where he's like I'm playing
it crazy you know he's just he seems so
naturally this guy yeah and if you watch
enough Jason Momoa interviews this seems
more like Jason Momoa now more than ever
weirdly even because he's in a
villainous shoes but he's so aware of
what the world is that it needs that
that the scenes with him
like okay by comparison him and Jason
Statham I don't find that in Vin Diesel
and Jason Statham I don't find that
interesting when they're talking to each
other Vin Diesel and Cypher I don't find
that interesting when they were talking
to each other in any of the films Vin
Diesel and John Cena in the last one
don't find that interesting but as you
said the contrast between the two
different types of personalities just
when they're interacting with each other
it's actually engaging like if any of
those rumors are true about Vin Diesel
being upset about Jason Momoa in the
show like my God you would be doing
yourself a massive disservice because he
helps make you more interested
when Vin Diesel is this is my my
takeaway with the cast was he's one of
the least interesting people because
he's he's fun when he's like I like
watching him in the action just because
of the Ridiculousness of this this Godly
presence that Vin Diesel inhabits of
being that just uh redefined Dominic
Toretto over this franchise
but he does make him a more interesting
character than ever than the last few
films have made him and so you need Jace
like Vin Diesel needs Jason Moet for Vin
Diesel to be more interesting yeah well
I think it circumvents some of that
stuff I mean I don't know what the
actual contracts are but it circumvents
the things that can become also boring
about the stakes from what we know about
that to have just a guy who yeah is here
to torture him and he almost never he's
so often talking to him over
walkie-talkies or from afar and he's
just trying to bust his chops and make
him sweat and I think that's a great way
to have Vin Diesel take some hits
without having literally taking some
hits yeah and he's a villain who's
willing to get hit yeah totally and get
hurt he really is just I just love how
the more you break it down he is just
Joker without the mystery even right
down to like giving you choices and [__]
like that and testing yes exactly
you know Joker yeah which yeah I think
uh this franchise I think the further it
has arced into that Superhero you know
Larger than Life territory I think one
thing that they have kind of overlooked
is the idea that you do need a larger
than life villain who's not just you
know mean mugging and trying to out
muscle you know whoever you know Vin
Diesel whoever
um and yeah I mean like I think some of
the plot elements didn't always serve
the characters but I was always happy to
be with any set of characters we cut to
I know uh the the Roman tejan stuff
wasn't like the most engaging plot but I
still liked hanging out with them I
still like getting to meet Pete like
Pete Davidson Cameo uh real quick and
and you know various of the like Cipher
and uh and Letty I think is like a cool
Prospect for the future well they see
Chris Morgan is did not write this and
it was Justin Lynn and some other guy
Dan something so
um yeah what has he done I don't know I
just know his name because it sounds
like miso from Mr Sunday movies
yeah I don't I don't know what else this
guy has done and I feel like that's
where Chris Morgan's chops come in handy
is for handling Roman
because I felt like this was the most
boring Teja ever was sure that that
whole section of them
like it started off engaging like I like
I liked the setup of oh this is Roman
taking the lead and it actually could
have done something a little more
interesting that they could have leaned
into with they they acknowledge it they
have a scene that talks about it how
this was Roman's you know chance to take
a lead and he total and essentially the
whole thing got botched so it could have
been something that was more they could
even lean not I don't even mean lean
into it in a way with like dramatic
weight I I they could have deleted to it
with like comedy even they could have
done something but it was so
underwritten and it ranged from
mediocreally entertaining watching them
to just honestly boring it was years it
was always in that range for me of
mediocre to boring if they'd really
embraced yeah that role that loss for
him and that kind of crisis of just like
my role on the team and my my wanting to
step up like yeah if they had really
embraced that that could have been an
endearing thing for those characters to
do rather than devolving into just like
ah we gotta chase a bunch of mcguffins
and money and stuff around and just like
genuinely fun banter like that wasn't
even existing there the whole thing with
like uh Han tripping out honestly one of
the things such a missed opportunity I
feel like the last couple films have
really botched is Han you know part of
me was going is he's just still like
weird grieving guy right now like I was
kind of getting it with the character
portrayed on the last one because he's
been like an assassin or some [__] I
don't know my memory barely serves me on
what they said about it what he's been
doing uh
and I was like is he missing Giselle
this time around or something but then I
wait no I mean you see him in Tokyo
Drift if you're going by order of
timeline
that was after giselle's death and he is
a blast to watch in Tokyo Drift so here
Han returning was such an exciting thing
and they don't do anything really with
Han that makes him fun and he's like
actually kind of boring now he's owed a
big moment or something and the big
moment ought to have come with his
confrontation with Shaw yeah and that
just turned into a whatever fight scene
a quick snack fight and then a quick way
to resolve their their score basically
yeah when that could have been uh the
thing that we were all kind of waiting
for that they even teased in the trailer
and it would have been hype yeah and it
didn't they didn't do anything with it
and I like Jason Statham's presence a
lot I really feel like he adds something
this is one of those franchises where
the celebrities that really do feel add
something
um even if they're on screen only
briefly because like he's only there for
a minute and two like the other you know
it's like Scott Eastwood shows up for a
half a second and like they all like I
noticed that was like even though you
have your main components of the
characters you're mainly cutting to even
the people who are just part of the
overall franchise who don't spend much
time in the movie I didn't really feel
like we're slighted by that fact
Cipher this is even though this is the
least amount of screen time she gets in
a fast and furious movie this is to me
the best she's ever been she was easily
the most fun to watch this time around
something about putting her in the muck
of things having her be introduced in a
way that is a much more gritty and grimy
like she's beating up she's against
she's not the top dog like sure last
time she's like imprisoned whatever
she's still like neat and prettied up
and whatever and she still like gives
that air of being in control yeah and
here having to like figure her way out
even as ridiculous as it is with you
know the whole thing with her what
device they left by her hand but her
scenes are actually entertaining she's I
I always thought that it's Charlize
Theron and they just gave her stoic
boring villain yeah and the last two
films like there was always something
that I felt could have reached a much
higher potential and here I actually
found that this is where they captured
the energy that Charlize Theron could
bring right down to her fight scenes
which I thought were great great uh
anytime she was on screen I actually
thought like here this is what I've this
is Charlie stair like yeah this is the
star right here I find you very
entertaining right now and anytime she
was on screen and I'm actually excited
to see her in the future with Letty in
that whatever Odd Couple you know
relationship that's gonna lead to down
the line and you know her ultimate
retribution I'm sure yeah now what do
you think about John Cena being redone
uh hey man I mean like it was such a
blast to watch him and I actually really
enjoyed him and little B together uh you
know praise be the base God uh yeah like
I I was
you know you're in congress with the
previous installment or not I just
enjoyed watching him that much more and
I think they're smart enough to know
that yeah his Charisma and his fun
energy is a big you know thing people
come for but also something that these
movies I think can use it's uh I I
forgive it because yeah even though he
was a super intense last time I think
you know this movies these movies need
as many splashes of Personality as they
can get and you know even though like
some of the most ridiculous stuff like
them coming on the plane and everything
is like again hyper ridiculous uh I I
was still really into that and I liked
the family aspect of that and even
though I don't think he's dead I like
the idea of wondering anyway so yeah I
mean I don't mind them completely
changing the character or anything like
that and uh and I liked uh the addition
of Brie Larson for like the the small
amount she's not like the most impactful
character they add but you know to to
flesh out Mr nobody's family I thought
she got to strut some of that coolness
and some of that attitude that you know
everything you see Brie Larson and now
you're like
so is this gonna hearken to what could
be improved about her portrayal of
Captain Marvel and uh you know watching
this I'm like okay like yeah you can
bring some of that attitude and some of
that SASS and whatnot and I hope they
give her more to do next time
um yeah I think they'll probably give
her more to do it's pretty Larson
they're setting her up absolutely and I
mean just so many like crazy cool like
the the whole bomb through Rome I
thought was a nice they literally
pointed out for us in the movie but I
thought it was a nice Counterpoint to
the safe thing and two watching them
kind of re-contextualize I mean these
movies are like Saw movies in the sense
that like every next installment is
based off of something that was like
just in the Next Room from one of the
last sequels or something and uh and I
think that's that's a fun gag but I also
thought that the way they showed you the
opposite perspectives was nicely at
least in this immediate experience
nicely handled and I thought Louis
letaria overall just stepping into the
director role brought a lot of energy
and made it really kind of
flow more than I expect these movies to
flow I think he's a very underrated
director sure I I think an Incredible
Hulk movie I feel like as an
underwriting movie overall especially
the action scenes that he has there I
think are very exciting sequences I I
loved a lot of the fights that he does
there The Transporter movies that he
held I thought are really really really
fun uh so it's cool seeing him reunite
with Jason Statham here
um John and I are the only fans of the
movie the one with Jet Li yeah so I
overall I think he's a very underrated
director because he knows how to make a
really entertaining film and he had big
shoes to fill at a last minute decision
you know with Justin Lin stepping away
three days before or something yeah he
had a real tough tough situation and a
big challenge ahead of him and while I I
don't really often find you know what
makes it's it's always difficult for me
to truly pinpoint what makes their style
distinct when it comes to the Fast and
Furious franchises only once in a I'll
be like I guess this kind of looks like
a shot from that director that I know
but more often than not it's like what I
like about Louis the Terrier's work is
he he has a good spirit about it and I
feel like that Spirit he really brings
here brings it to life and he's got just
the right amount of cheese in order to
make it to still enjoyable like he
brings a sense of self-awareness to her
like this was the the first one in a
couple films where I felt like the the
gravity toss never weighed the film down
even though clearly Vin Diesel still
really wants that he's moving I never
felt like it reached a point where this
is too much and it's boring so I really
I really do credit his work and I think
I don't know whose decision it was for
John Cena uh to come back around like
this but I didn't even like John Cena in
the last movie took a lot of the fun out
of watching John Cena yeah I thought I
found myself laughing at him a lot well
that's the thing is this this also had
the right kind of cheese and it's very
easy as we've seen in the last two
installments especially actually to fall
into the wrong kind of cheese that does
not help the experience yeah and Brie
Larson's like fun and Charming is there
a chance to actually be herself a little
bit more as well like I think that's
part of the fun of when you cast these
guys is seeing them get to be more what
they're really like and I think the
franchise has been smart enough to lean
into that with a lot of these cast of
characters Alan richson uh was
essentially doing what we know from Jack
Reacher to be just with a villainous
twist yes he's not as well jackridge was
a lot smarter
but it's just pretty much it's very much
a Jack Reacher kind of role uh and and
all if Jack Reacher wasn't a loner
um but yeah that was that was fine if I
didn't recognize his build at the
beginning I would I don't think I would
have predicted it I mean even even
wrecking even recognizing his build at
the beginning I still didn't ultimately
predict it I was like oh maybe I just
misread it yeah sure that's a great
catch though yeah his body looks he's
very large man yeah yeah you know he's
got he's got a very specific looking
build and I mean uh Danielle and
melchior I thought like she's hardly in
this but I'm excited to see her a little
bit more maybe hopefully in the next one
she's family now and I thought the kitty
was a little Brian did a fine job if
yeah he did a fine job everyone did good
everyone did good overall don't know
what happened with Mia but sure she was
around for a little bit
um she's chilling I feel like uh they
should she's seeing that the house gets
rebuilt a third time yeah yeah overall I
thought this was a really fun movie and
of course the action scenes
they were they didn't just feel like
noise to me you know I I thought there
was a lot of Craftsmen shipped to the
action yeah the bomb through Rome as
insane as it is as not realistic as it
is it was I was still able to follow it
and you could still tell when a lot of
stuff was practical yeah tangible still
you got to mix on a lot and that's where
tangible's the right word for it because
I think the franchise lost a lot of its
tangibility yeah you have to have this
right realm of I believe what's
happening you need the stunts and you
need some real destruction because that
especially in movies that center around
cars that sells everything yeah I think
especially F9 and fate of the Furious
got to that point where you're like if
you're doing all CG you know that's in a
movie like this that is very much
straddling the line of like all the
craziness is done with very real
machines you could see go outside and
see you need yeah that grounding in the
Practical stunt worked at least for the
things that can be achieved that way
well yeah they always have had a bit of
practical stunt work but they it tends
to get kind of lost I think and here it
didn't ever get lost for me well here it
seemed like a priority to do it in
camera when they could yeah uh it's that
sequence even the even the race car I
remember seeing the trailer and laughing
at the fact that they have a race car
sequence happening here like what this
is weird but with the objectives and
that Jason Momoa has with the way how he
loves the toy with people and how he is
kind of doing this thing where he wants
to prey on memory and he's doing this
there's a there's a real uh theatrical
dramatic experience that he tries to
provide with the suffering you know
he'll flat out say like see what I did
with the with the bomb it was the play
on the on the safe or um this is the
freeway where it all happened you know
like he likes to have this these
theatrics that I think are a lot of fun
yeah and he's defacing these sacred cows
things like that yeah and so even going
to the race car I'm like okay this
actually it actually works sometimes
they are Dom's home now sometimes you
try to shoehorn the racing back in here
and you're like this doesn't need to be
here but this actually worked it really
it was it was actually kind of clever of
how they brought it back in
um yeah I don't the it sure just I
didn't in the middle number but I don't
ever come here for
I mean I don't know for structure I
don't realize I showed up for like
like a complete narrative
and and then of all the franchises ever
I mean this is one where you you know
the story is not ending so why not you
know there's enough of a climax that
it's clear this is a chapter break and
at worst it feels like you know some
mid-season finale work it's clear we'll
be back yeah
um I feel like they should still end it
on I don't know if a two more is where
they should do I still think they should
end it in the next one uh like the
original plan that they had we'll see
yeah I I I I feel like they could find
stuff to do but part of me is like man
if they could just nail a one-two punch
to send things off that would be pretty
gratifying actually after all this
because I mean for the ups and downs the
fast franchise I would argue that for
fans for for people who enjoy these it's
probably got more it's got a decent
record between hits and misses so like
they I don't know the Yeah the more you
expand this out the more worried I get
even though I'm sure they don't want to
stop just yet also making less and less
money in the states it's not is this is
not considered a
I feel like it's actually not considered
a success in the states uh it's just why
they're really not digital uh sure yeah
um but the but the film internationally
is doing extremely well yeah uh as it
should with its multiple ethnic cats it
should do very very well yeah it's Globe
trotting everyone's represented in the
fast family
they pretty much are sure I mean it's a
very Multicultural family and it's and
they go all over the world and and even
though they destroy a lot of it they
seem to appreciate it when they're not
trying to destroy it yeah well uh I
don't know what do you guys think about
the movie did you guys like it overall
did you have fun with it I I think this
was a I think this was a good return to
a genuinely enjoyable film and I had I
had a lot of fun with it and uh
glad we bought it it was worth the money
alrighty guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below uh you can subscribe leave a
like and let's end this with a patron
flev
DeLorean because they had a new DeLorean
in this movie and if there's anybody I
would love to see you know peel up uh
and you know Screech come to a
screeching halt you know tires blazing
and then throwing open those Gull Wing
doors and stepping out and informing me
that I have two seconds to decide
whether or not to get in the car with
you I would get in that car with you I
would trust you with my life Flav no
matter what crazy Globe spanning mystery
Espionage Mission you are on I will
trust you if you look at me you know
when we're on top of a crumbling
building or something and you're like
John do you trust me I would be like of
course Flav I will jump off of anything
you tell me to I will drive into
anything you tell me to and I will act
without thinking if you tell me to nice
that's what we do for family flev and
you can't spell flev
uh without you know the letter F which
is the first letter of the word family
and there's also an L in family and
that's the second letter of your name
and uh and your last name has an i in it
so we're halfway to family already
buddies so uh keep up the good work keep
saving the world and we'll catch you
next time love you stay pledged
I don't know how you doing John
it's the NOS
[Music]
foreign